[Musique]
il est vraiment si dangereux que ça
regarde
c'est incroyable
plonge
bien par là et tu t'apprêtes mon épée
et si on courait
alors comment tu fais ça rien de spécial
je galope c'est tout
notre palefrenier est un bon oeil
intégral mais les journaux d'or non mais
quelle frime on ne peut pas lui couper
la tête comme sa
majesté
confusément une mission mais pas trop
facile il faut au moins qu'il y ait du
danger mais quel idiot alors ça tu tombe
bien trash arrive à ckoi ivan ton de
sarah dorette a confié une tâche que nul
ne peut réussir
que tu cheval regarde
c'est un monde où règne la magie et
l'illusion la route sera longue
le tarn on voit vous cherchez
attention vous risquer de tomber
[Musique]
oh
je t'aurais bien rattrapé plus tôt mais
mais elle était un peu engourdie
et comme il fallait s'y attendre ce
benêt est tombé amoureux de moi
une princesse doit épouser un roe
atteint par cronje
faire une raison
prépare toi on s'en va non il est encore
plus têtu qu'une mule
parce que seul un authentique nigaud
comme toi se préoccupent plus des autres
que de lui même serveur
[Musique]
c'est magnifique
continue comme ça bouge toi les oreilles
[Musique]
j'ai mal
dis moi le vent situe où elle se trouve
cette bague par la baleine géante
elle a été avalée
avec elle
[Musique]
attention aux pays bas